[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a japanese romance drama film
called my tomorrow your yesterday
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
it is the 15th of february a 20 year old
boy named takatoshi minamiyama from
kyoto encounters a beautiful girl named
imi fujuku on a train while on his way
to college he is instantly smitten by
her and he calls it love at first sight
takatoshi is a visual arts undergraduate
student and political satirist takatoshi
is shy by nature and initially
suppresses his feelings but ultimately
decides to approach her he deliberately
misses his stop to talk to her after
getting off at her station he awkwardly
tells her that he has fallen in love
with her and asks for her email
takatoshi doesn't sound shy to me when
she tells him that she doesn't have an
email takatoshi thinks she is turning
him down and proceeds to leave but amy
stops him and assures him that she
really doesn't use an email the two then
sit on a bench and get to know each
other aimee reveals that she is a 20
year old cosmetology student and she
recently moved to the city when amy asks
him why he wanted to talk to her out of
all the girls on the train takatoshi
tells her that he felt a sudden instinct
to approach her which he can't explain
in words he says that he felt like he
has known her for a long time takatoshi
proceeds to tell her something about the
takara gaiiki lake but imi suddenly gets
up and tells him that she has to get
going before parting ways takatoshi asks
aimee if they will meet again this for
some reason makes her emotional and she
says until tomorrow before leaving at
school takatoshi tells his best friend
shoiichi uiyama who is good with girls
about imi uyama finds it hard to believe
that a shy nerd like takatoshi asked a
girl for her phone number meanwhile the
latter is worried if he will meet emi
again and uiyama assures him that emi
will come looking for him the next day
takatoshi looks for emi on the train but
doesn't see her dejected he goes to the
zoo to draw sketches for his assignment
to his surprise aimee approaches him at
the zoo she compliments his drawing and
comments that his school should
definitely display his work however
takatoshi is puzzled wondering how emi
found him at the zoo imi tells him that
he told her his plans at the zoo in
their last meeting and changes the topic
takatoshi is puzzled as to when he said
this but he is soon cut off by emi she
asks him what he wanted to tell her
about the takara gaiiki lake the last
time and takatoshi tells her that it is
one of his favorite places he takes her
there and reveals that he once fell off
the pier and almost drowned in the lake
when he was saved by a woman amy reveals
that she too once almost died when she
was five this is a strange coincidence
that both of them share this time amy
gives takatoshi her phone number before
parting ways after returning home
takatoshi tells uiyama that he finally
got emi's number and uiyama encourages
him to ask her out on a date takatoshi
obliges and calls her but doesn't know
how to ask her out so uyama writes cards
for him and helps him the next day
takatoshi learns that his school has
displayed his drawing on the board
following the tips from his friend
takatoshi goes to explore his dating
spot by himself so he could be as
confident as possible before meeting emi
takatoshi then takes emi to the same
spot and shows her an awesome time he
also takes her to a movie and the date
goes really well at the end of the date
takatoshi musters the courage to ask
aimee to be his girlfriend imi points
out her flaws such as her emotions but
takatoshi tells her that he loves
everything about her this too makes the
girl tear up the next day she shows up
at takatoshi's house to help him move to
his new apartment where she finally
meets his best friend ueyama after
moving the stuff in uyama leaves but
eemi stays with takatoshi to help him
organize his apartment she finds a
mysterious box in one of the large
carton boxes and takatoshi reveals that
he met the woman who saved him from
drowning at the lake at a market five
years ago and she gave him the box he
also reveals that she asked him not to
open the box until they meet again after
arranging his home takatoshi walks imi
to the station and on the way he musters
up some courage and nervously asks if he
can hold her hand she obliges and they
hold each other's hand for the first
time takatoshi is extremely happy as he
is holding a girl's hand for the first
time while imi gets emotional and begins
crying again imi and takatoshi start
spending more and more time with each
other amy cooks for him and her cooking
surprises him as her food tastes just
like his mother's cooking eemi
speculates that maybe his mother adds
chocolate in her food just like her this
surprises takatoshi as he had never told
her that his mother adds chocolate in
her dishes takatoshi finds it strange
that emi is able to predict things about
his life as she had earlier predicted
that his drawing of a giraffe should be
displayed at the school however emi
laughs it off and asks him what he would
do if she could predict the future
takatoshi jokingly replies that he would
gamble all day and become filthy rich at
least takatoshi is honest the two
continue to spend more time together and
on the 15th day the two make love which
again makes aimee emotional it is
getting late again and takatoshi walks
emi to the train station after returning
home takatoshi finds aimee's journal on
his table and goes through it lo and
behold the diary contains future
predictions of the next 15 days the
first entry is dated march 16th while
the last entry is march 1st in an entry
from march 15th amy has written that she
met takatoshi's parents it seems amy has
written them as if she is racing through
time backwards takatoshi then receives a
call from aimee and it is revealed that
she deliberately left the diary on his
table she promises to tell him
everything and asks him to meet her
tomorrow in his classroom at 6am she
also asks him to bring the mysterious
box with him just as the clock strikes
12 and before takatoshi could get a word
in imi disappears from the phone booth
like a ghost the next day aimee meets
him in the classroom and tells him that
she is from a parallel world where time
moves in the opposite direction in other
words what's the future for takatoshi is
the past for imi and vice versa this
explains how eemi knew that takatoshi's
picture was going to be displayed in his
school takatoshi is stunned by the
revelation and doesn't believe any of it
at first but when amy tells her how she
knew of his mother's secret recipe
without ever meeting her he starts
trusting her aimee then opens the box
that the woman who saved takatoshi from
drowning gave to him takatoshi is
shocked to see a picture of amy with his
parents and him she explains that the
picture is from her past i.e his future
eemi has been watching takatoshi from
afar since he was young and she was the
adult woman who saved him and gave him
the box it is also revealed that
takatoshi will save her from dying when
she will be five because her memories of
him fade as time goes on and her time
goes backwards she keeps a journal to
remind her of him she also tells him
that they can only be together for a
month every five years because that's
when aimee's universe and takatoshi's
universe synchronizes moreover 20 is the
only time that their age matches and the
current month is the last time where
they can pursue a relationship despite
them fast drifting apart amy tries to
enjoy the moment but takatoshi feels
conflicted about the fake nature of his
and emi's relationship he tells her that
he can't continue like this saying he
doesn't want to enact a script from
someone's diary he meets his friend at
the laundry shop and without revealing
any details he tells him that eemi and
he are moving past each other takatoshi
compares eemi and himself to the earth
and moon that's drifting away four
centimeters from each other every year
however uyama makes him realize that it
gives them all the more reason to make
the best of the time they have left
together suddenly takatoshi comprehends
the reason why aimee used to get
emotional all the time takatoshi's first
meeting with aimee on the train is
actually aimee's last but emi still acts
as if she has met takatoshi for the
first time realizing this takatoshi
becomes devastated as emi has been
sacrificing her feelings just to stay
relevant with the timeline he then
immediately calls her and apologizes to
her from that day on the two spend their
remaining days together cherishing every
moment they have on march 15th takatoshi
takes aimee to his hometown he shows her
his favorite restaurant amy loves the
food and stomps her foot on the ground
like a child in excitement in a
flashback scene takatoshi tells amy that
he only plays football because his dad
loves to see him playing it he tells her
that when he grows up he wants to be a
comic artist back to the present the
lovebirds go to meet takatoshi's parents
they are given a cold welcome by his
father but his mother is elated to see
his girlfriend takatoshi's mother makes
dinner for them and tells aimee about
his childhood when takatoshi's father
leaves after having dinner his mother
tells aimee that he only acts cold in
front of others but deep down he cares a
lot about his son the couple then takes
the same family picture from the box
before leaving on their way back
takatoshi breaks into tears despairing
over the family he won't get to start
with eemi march 16th finally arrives it
is the last day they would be together
as equals this is the last day for
takatoshi while it is the first day for
emi this eemi doesn't remember how
takatoshi and her spent the previous 30
days together as every midnight a new
eemi meets takatoshi they meet at
takatoshi's class because he has been
meaning to draw her since he first saw
her aimee has a diary in which she has
written how she broadly spends her time
with takatoshi according to what the 25
year old takatoshi told her so she asks
a 20 year old takatoshi to tell
everything about their time together in
the last 30 days in as much detail as
possible she asks him this as from now
on she intends to use this updated diary
to relive their time together takatoshi
then delightfully explains to her about
the blissful days while drawing her this
brings him to tears later takatoshi
stays with emi till midnight a few
moments before midnight amy asks him
what kind of girlfriend she was and if
he was happy with her takatoshi tells
her that the last 30 days with her were
the best period of his life he also
tells her that they are not drifting
apart the edges have been tied into a
ring connecting them as one life the
clock finally strikes 12 and emi
disappears this makes takatoshi annoyed
but once he grasps reality he calms down
five years pass by takatoshi is now 25
he meets a 15 year old eemi and shows
her the painting he drew of her five
years ago aimee notes how the future
takatoshi is more mature and wonderful
takatoshi hopefully does not hit on the
15 year old eemi a further 10 years
later takatoshi rescues five-year-old
amy from a festival fire the film then
cuts to a montage of the film presented
from eemie's perspective in reverse
ending with her and takatoshi's
introduction on february 15th on the
train the last day she met him as equals
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching